all right let's get to some audience
questions starting with hey David in the
age of Trump what kind of charities or
causes do you think are the most
important ones to support I immediately
go to the causes and charities that are
going to defend the basic institutions
that are under attacked by the current
President on the basis of his
authoritarian tendencies so immediately
we've got to defend free speech
organizations and organizations working
on issues of speech we have seen Pat
significant and concerted attacks on
press freedom and also on demonstrations
I think that very very soon with the
Supreme Court pick that Donald Trump has
made you were going to see abortion
under attack not necessarily roe v--
wade but certainly at the state level a
variety of different proposals that may
ultimately make it up to the supreme
court to restrict access to abortion I
think that net neutrality organizations
working on net neutrality need to be
supported those are the ones that my
mind goes to right away yeah there are
so many really I think about child
protection charities right especially
when we talk about families being split
up there's also the environment right so
many charities there and those are
causes we should have been supporting
all along right groups like the Sierra
Club and you know the environments been
a big problem for a long time and
getting worse and worse but particularly
so under the Trump administration and
you know deregulation going on the
regulatory capture within the EPA so
those are two that I thought of yeah
climate changes are depressing one
because I obviously completely agree
with you
but at the same time given the sort of
bully pulpit and power that Trump has on
that issue are my donations to the
Sierra Club gonna do anything I mean III
don't I'm not saying it's a bad
organization and I'm not saying it's bad
to be activating around this I just am
very deflated about think it's it's sort
of like we've got an emergency and we've
got to vote them out in three and a half
months that's really the path forward I
just wish I felt like Sierra Club
donations could really stop what's going
on I just don't know that they can
here's another one I was too considering
what about contributing to like an LGBT
cause you know Republicans are typically
not very good on those issues after all
these opposed gay marriage for the
longest time but maybe we've moved past
that maybe you know there still are
organizations like The Trevor Project
out there that we should consider
donating to but is that particularly
more important under the Trump
administration than it would be under
Hillary Clinton or a Democrat yeah I
mean it is we we we've had in 2015 we
had the issue of state bans on same-sex
marriage resolved the Supreme Court
saying you can't do that but then the
new fight along LGBT issues has been
so-called religious freedom and finding
new ways basically to suppress LGBT
rights oh yeah I said there's no
shortage I think is the point but to get
back to the question of most important I
go with organizations defending actual
free speech on both the behalf of
individuals and the press as well as
organizations that are going to work on
Internet freedom and net neutrality and
campaign finance as well although that
that's not that's not unique to the
Trump Organization organization the
Trump administration so that that's an
area where I would you should always be
doing that funny you said the next
question I was going to ask if you were
going to contribute to the Trump
foundation to which is the well-known
charity yet if I want to support Trump
commissioning portraits of himself to go
up in his own golf clubs that's the
first donation that I'll make